[موسيقى]
في امريكا شوف في امريكا في يعني طرفين
في القياده الفكريه والقياده السياسيه في
طرف وهو المهيمن للاسف الان يريد اعداء او
يخلق عدو من الصين يعني ان يعيد ان يعيد
تاريخ الحرب البارده وان يبدل الاتحاد
السوفيتي بالصين انه الصين هو الان العدو
الكبير ولازم انه كل طاقات امريكا
العسكريه واستراتيجيه كلها ان تتجه
لعداء الصين او لمعاداه الصين انا ارى خطر
كبير في هذا الفكر وفي هذا المنحه
والاتجاه اولا الصين علاقتها بامريكا
مختلفه عن ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي لانه في
علاقات اقتصاديه يعني كبيره بين بين
الطرفين ومن الصعب جدا انه خلق الشرخ هذا
بين البلدين
اضافه ولكن في نفس الوقت هذا يصب في مصالح
كبيره امريكيه ان كانت في المصالح عسكريه
مصالح الصناعيه الى اخره بايدن من محبيذي
هذا الفكر العدائي اتجاه الصين
لم يكن كذلك يعني في عداء تجاه الصين ولكن
في كمان ممكن انه يتعامل معاه
[موسيقى]
مش بس المملكه يعني في دول اخرى حتى في
اسرائيل في مصر في تركيا في الهند
فرض
المنظومه هذه منظومه انه الصين هو العدو
الاول والاخير
انا اعتقد انه خطر جدا على امريكا وعلى
العالم
[موسيقى]